[Música]
economía aquí en directo América me
acompaña en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de la economía de China que ha
dejado de ser la fábrica del mundo quien
los Está reemplazando cuéntenos bueno en
un momento de tensiones geopolíticas y
luego de las duras medidas de cero covid
19 que impuso china muchas empresas ya
están buscando alternativas en Asia para
relocalizar a sus empresas un estudio
del peterson institute International
economic revela que las importaciones
desde china se han recuperado a un ritmo
más lento que antes del inicio de la
guerra comercial con la administración
de Donald Trump A diferencia de las
compras desde el resto del mundo las
importaciones desde otros países
asiáticos también están creciendo en
Estados Unidos Taiwán Corea del Sur y
Malasia están ganando partes de ese
mercado Pero dentro de China ocurre otro
fenómeno varias empresas como Apple DHL
Amazon o Microsoft están moviendo sus
plantas a otros países como India Japón
Taiwán Vietnam filipinas Tailandia y
hasta palacia las se las preguntamos a
Alejandro Godoy consultor geopolítico en
asuntos internacionales y docente de
posgrado de relaciones internacionales
en la universidad militar Nueva Granada
en Bogotá esto nos dijo
las cadenas de producción las cadenas de
valor se están moviendo a otros países
de Asia por todo este tema de tan
centralizado como sabemos en el puerto
de Shanghai que es el número uno del
planeta Entonces se está moviendo a
países como Vietnam como India como
Tailandia en este caso específico y como
comencé la guerra comercial eso
estableció una serie de estándares más
dados para que pueda moverse la
producción eso es algo que hay que
recordar y además sabemos que aunque no
sea Trump el presidente actual de los
Estados Unidos bailen también ha dado
una serie de mensajes bastante claros
sobre lo que es su relación con china el
año pasado se publicó el documento de
seguridad donde decía que el país de
cuidado que hay que tener en las
relaciones internacionales es China y
sabemos que Taiwán que tiene ahí un
papel preponderante sobre el tema
tecnológico de igual manera con
compañías tan grandes como ht donde
tiene un monopolio muy grande de los
semiconductores en este caso específico
básicamente
tienen ahí una una problemática bastante
grande usted ya nos daba algunas ideas
Jorge pero también los expertos ya
comienzan a hablar de una reorganización
del comercio mundial a raíz de este
fenómeno que se está presentando cuenta
bueno es que una encuesta de más de 500
empresas de Taiwán publicada por el
centro de estrategias y estudios
internacionales encontró que el 25,7% de
las empresas ya habían trasladado una
parte de su producción o abastecimiento
fuera de China y el 33,2 estaba pensando
en hacerlo la mayoría de los que
abandonaron china el 63,1% se
trasladaron al sudeste asiático muchas
empresas fueron afectadas por estos
brotes de covid-19 que provocó
confinamientos que perturbaron la
producción industrial y también las
cadenas logísticas esto hizo que a
finales del año pasado las exportaciones
de China cayeran hasta un 8,7%
interanual según los datos de la agencia
aduanera este motivos los detalla
nuestro invitado sin duda tiene un
problema muy grande que es el
envejecimiento de su población ya vemos
que tiene un tercio de su población por
encima de los sesenta y cuatro años y
que el cierre del dos fue un y será un
gran reto para el futuro de china porque
en el caso particular tuvo ya un un
déficit de cerca de ochocientos mil
ochocientos cuarenta mil nacimientos en
este orden de ideas dónde van a estar
los nuevos trabajadores Entonces en un
primer punto y resumiendo muy
rápidamente está ese contexto de bueno
trabajadores necesarios dos las
protestas que vimos a final de año
también por todo lo que fueron los
cierres tan consecutivos y que aún no se
ha recuperado totalmente la producción
en varias zonas tres también lo que se
ha visto con empresas grandes de
construcción como evergent en este caso
particular y el descontento de parte de
la población y el cuarto
que Estados Unidos por supuesto ha
bloqueado la posibilidad que tiene China
de comprar máquinas de semiconductores
chips y demás no solamente a Taiwán sino
también para la producción en en socios
europeos importantes que tiene Estados
Unidos como los Países Bajos Entonces en
este caso particular si es interesante y
llamativo como encuentra unos bloqueos
fuertes para poder seguir apostándole a
la robótica y demás Muchas gracias Jorge
por esta especial de economía en torno a
la economía del país
asiático de China a continuación una
semana en el mundo
[Música]